I think a lot of people under charge I
mean I used to race cars full-size cars
I used to have a guy used to do a lot of
the mechanic him for me on that car and
I'll deliver it to him and tell me what
he's done and he said 75 quid sorry
about that and I think God expecting 200
pound on that bill and like I have 125
really yeah yeah you have it he went out
of business and I know why he went out
of business I told him why he was gonna
go out of business and he wasn't
charging enough
you know but he was so afraid and I
don't know why people don't try because
trying to charge a little more is an
experiment in business isn't it and you
push it to as far as you can because you
can only make that profit once from that
customer you know you don't want to rip
anyone off I would never
say go and rip people off but you're
providing value and it's what you put us
that value and that's an important
amount of money